c'est un feuilleton culte des années 60
diffusé à l'époque sur l'eau et rtf
l'homme du picardie tout le monde se
souvient de cette série le comédien
principal christian barbier est mort en
2009 mais la péniche elle existe
toujours et près de 41 ans après la
première diffusion la série à succès est
encore dans toutes les têtes notamment
celle des mariniers c'est le grand
format que nous avons choisi de vous re
diffusé cette semaine il est préparé par
dominique patinec jean-louis croci et
patricia banque regarder
[Musique]
à graville tout le monde connaît la
péniche cette boîte de nuit aménagé dans
un bateau
mais les danseurs qui se pressent sur sa
piste quand il jamais entendu parler de
l'homme du picardie
car la péniche a connu plusieurs vies
picardie fut son nom le temps d'un
feuilleton
[Musique]
ce bateau qui descend la marne c'est le
picardy un automoteur de 38 m le
capitaine seul homme joseph durtol ses
parents étaient mariniers il est
mariniers le picardie c'est son bateau
les restes durtol les teams hermans
fille de mariniers belge elle est la
femme du capitaine est aussi son matelot
première diffusion à la télévision la
france se passionne pour la famille
durtol thérèse et joseph les parents
yvette et julien leurs enfants julien
rôles marquants pour pierre santini
attendez j'ai fait beaucoup de séries et
feuilletons mais l'homme du picardie
c'est ce qui revient tout le temps
le picard débat alors aujourd'hui ils
ont du mal à imaginer qu'il était le
fils de 25 ans mais beaucoup de gens me
dire ah mais vous pouvez pas savoir me
courait
télévisée toute ta famille s'arrêter
libre pour pendant un quart d'heure pour
voir l'épisode du rhum du tout comme les
humoristes d'aujourd'hui brocarde une
épopée immobile un feuilleton dans
lequel il ne se passe rien il devrait
réviser leurs classiques nos mariniers
vive moult déboires et de ses déboires
christian barbier le premier responsable
l'homme du picardie est un tyran les
bougon il est tyran domestique il est
macho il est enfin il ya la pluie c'est
pas un héros positifs
mais peut-être que dans la vraie vie les
héros positifs ils sont rares aussi et
surtout se pressent dans les puces comme
acquis courir je ne les aurais pas créé
à verneuil singh est une croix très bien
écrit mais était libre personnes avaient
commandé à durtol c'est une sorte de de
présence comme ça évident il ya des
comédiens comme ça et christian il avait
ce poids là je crois en bus un homme
les cieux cette présence
les mariniers eux mêmes la salue l'homme
du picardie fait partie du patrimoine à
longueil-annel quelques séquences ont
été tournées au coeur de la cité des
bateliers
oui on salue barbier le comédien mais
durtol lui ne remporte pas tous les
suffrages
peter darbee je vais très très bien
drôle du reggae mais on était mal an par
exemple on peut voir le marine et mal
rasé et puis il reconnaît qu'il y avait
le couteau tout ça descend on est passé
pas même encore maintenant l'apprécient
pas mon père par exemple mais n'aurait
jamais mur on te le matin fin de la
guerre avec les portes et même d'accord
avec mon père quant au talent de barreur
de l'homme du picardie
il est temps de révéler la vérité un
petit secret comme il est à la barre
ceux qui ont regardé le film y croyait
gtli qui compte déjà deux moteurs à
l'été c'était pas lui étaient posées par
quelqu'un de ma famille c'était les
propriétaires du bateau d'ailleurs ils
étaient planqués dans une cage et qu'on
disait avec un servomoteur
nos marines et son redoutable ils
connaissent les canaux de france parker
et ont vite fait de repérer toutes les
astuces de montage
la péniche de durtol s'égare parfois
c'est la magie de la télévision péché
vite pardonné les hauteurs de l'homme du
picardie ont compris l'essence du métier
un métier fait de solidarité
rose c'est une corporation qu on est
très solidaire je suis un bateau gabarit
ou quelque chose le premier équipage si
j'arrête ça y est pas le problème
en travaillant toujours ensemble de
retrouver
guillon procès
à
une façon de dire parce que travailler
autour club
et quelquefois plus parce que non
seulement très vite
les enfants les jeux ça se pouvait le
ménage et l'approvisionnement et tour et
en plus se donner la main aux
c'est emmanuel assi copieurs
le métier était difficile en 1968 il
l'est encore plus aujourd'hui
les mariniers peine à gagner leur vie
calme plat sur la scène se baigneurs ne
sera pas dérangé par les penny de plus
en plus rares le monde change et les
familles avec lui jean paul tribout
souri aux souvenirs de ses enfants sages
que lui et ses camarades devaient camper
c'est parce que je voyais en est sûr
rené qu'est ce que tu dirais si je vais
vivre avec toi moi
commence à vivre avec mon aiguille la
pêche et pas n'importe où comme tu
voudras h
moi je suis moi qui te raconter à tes
parents d'abord qu'est-ce qu'ils
tiraient ce m'est égal
bon faut pas dire ça l'est les parents
c'est importance c'est quand même des
parents ils vont repartir avec le bateau
moi je peux quitter
c'est vrai que jacques ertaud le
réalisateur était un personnage
contradictoire parce que il avait une
vraie modernité dans ce qu'on faisait
d'une manière ce bien consciente et en
même temps idéologiquement ce n'était
pas d'extrême gauche 1
mais moins qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'il
était conservateur voire parfois
réactionnaire filmer la fiction comme la
réalité et il voulait que la fiction
ressemble plus à la réalité que la rive
est elle-même et avec les comédiens elle
était comme ça quand un comédien tout
d'un coup parlait pas tout à fait juste
tout n'était pas naturelle puisqu'elle
écrit il pour la caisse qui était faux
départ tétines et manger parce qu'il est
mais était-ce elle mettait dans un état
invraisemblable parce que pour lui
c'était plus la vie je rêvais d'être
acteur les fonds du monde pour pour une
figuration dans un vrai théâtre mais mon
père m'a dit tu seras professeur et je
n'ai pas osé lui répondre
il était immense et brutale non ma seule
révolte fut de choisir la langue
anglaise comme discipline encore un buso
théâtre télévision cinéma pierre santini
a endossé de nombreux rôles mais l'homme
du picardie occupe une place à part dans
sa mémoire
la post et à des risques importants pour
moi parce que ça peut le rêve de
l'acteur aussi de laisser dans la
mémoire affective des gens dans la
mémoire sensorielle des gens simples
mémoire intellectuelle de laisser une
trace
cette trace les comédiens d'aujourd'hui
auront bien du mal à laisser ce n'est
pas une question de talent simplement la
télévision cet étrange lucarne est
devenu un objet banal loin du frisson
procurer en 68 lorsque retentit c'est la
musique
[Musique]